und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend solche Meldungen gab es
lange nicht mehr die ukrainische Armee
hat in den letzten Tagen dutzende
Ortschaften im Gebiet karkiff im Osten
des Landes zurückerobert das russische
Verteidigungsministerium räumte heute
ein es habe seine Truppen zurückgezogen
regelrecht weggerannt sein die Russen
spotten die Ukraine die offenbar mit
ihrer
überrumpelungsstrategie Erfolg hatten
schwer zu sagen ob das eine Wende im
Ukraine Krieg sein könnte Thomas
Reichert und Dalia anta fassen zusammen
was heute geschah
ein Video das ukrainische Soldaten auf
dem Weg durch die Region creson zeigen
soll und Menschen die ihre Freude nicht
zurückhalten es könnte ein Einschnitt
sein die Ukraine rückt vor erobert Orte
zurück im Osten im Süden am Abend
verkündete lensky weitere Geländegewinne
unsere Soldaten bewegen sich weiter in
verschiedene Richtungen entlang der
Front seit Anfang September wurden etwa
2000 Quadratkilometer unseres
Territoriums bereits befreit
heute Nachmittag die Nachricht des
kobians von ukrainischen Truppen
eingenommen worden sei ein strategisch
wichtiger Ort im Osten ebenso wichtig
neben kobiansk soll die Ukraine nun auch
Issum zurückerobert haben ein weiterer
Eisenbahnknoten der ukrainische Erfolg
wäre ein schwerer Schlag für Russlands
Nachschub offenbar werden russische
Truppen gerade von dort abgezogen das
räumt sogar Russlands
Verteidigungsministerium ein
und die erklärten Ziele der
sonderoperation zu Befreiung des Don
Bass zu erreichen wurde beschlossen die
in den Gebieten von balaklava und ishium
stationierten russischen Truppen um zu
gruppieren um die Bemühungen in Richtung
Donez zu verstärken zur gleichen Zeit
kommt am Rande von Kiew heute Vormittag
Überraschungsbesuch aus Deutschland
Außenministerin baerbock will sich
erklären lassen wie sie hier russische
Minen Räumen und zeigt sich schockiert
das selbst im Kinderspielzeug in
privaten Wohnungen Minen gefunden worden
sind die offensichtlich nichts anderes
zum Ziel hatten als unschuldige Menschen
selbst Kinder zu töten
baerbock glaubt Putin spekuliere darauf
dass Europa der Ukraine Hilfe
überdrüssig werde zum Abschluss ihrer
Reise verspricht baerbock Unterstützung
das gilt militärisch aber das gilt
genauso für den Wiederaufbau dieses
Landes Orte die befreit worden sind die
brauchen jetzt alles die brauchen
funktionierende Infrastruktur wir müssen
Schulen wieder Dächer beschaffen wir
müssen Krankenhäuser die beschossen
worden sind zum laufen bringen wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass die vielen
vielen Menschen die innerhalb der
Ukraine vertrieben worden sind jetzt in
zum Teil zerstörten Häusern wohnen dass
die gut durch den Winter kommen können
die russische Armee habe mit ihrer
Flucht eine gute Entscheidung getroffen
sagt selenski am Abend Besatzer hätten
in der Ukraine keinen Platz
nur langsam tastet sich die ukrainische
Armee in die zurückeroberten Dörfer vor
und was sie findet ist Zerstörung
verschreckte Menschen und vermiete
Straßen unsere Reporterin Katrin
Eigendorf hat die ersten
Erkundungstrupps der ukrainischen
Polizei begleitet
unterwegs in der Region hakif noch sind
überall die Spuren der Kämpfe zu sehen
vor drei Tagen erst haben ukrainische
Soldaten die Dörfer hier befreit die
mehr als sechs Monate von der russischen
Armee besetzt waren wir begleiten ein
Team der ukrainischen Polizei in gracove
ein Ort 60 Kilometer östlich von rakif
die russischen Soldaten haben nach ihrer
Flucht Munition und Panzer
zurückgelassen das gesamte Dorf so
berichten die Beamten sei vermiet
jetzt kommen hier die Techniker die
alles entminen wir sprechen mit den
Menschen wir leisten auch psychologische
Hilfe und bringen humanitäre
Unterstützung
was genau mit den 750 Dorfbewohnern
geschah soll jetzt ermittelt werden ein
Polizist zeigt uns ein Haus in dem die
russischen Soldaten offenbar ihr Lager
hatten was aus den Besitzern wurde ist
unklar nur vereinzelt trauen die
Menschen sich heraus nachdem sie sich
monatelang versteckt hielten
ungefähr 40 Menschen sind noch geblieben
die die kein Geld haben und nirgendwohin
können
vom Kirchturm aus sollen die russischen
Soldaten immer wieder auf die Einwohner
geschossen haben am Boden liegen noch
die leeren Patronenhülsen ein Team von
Ermittlern geht einem Hinweis nach dass
am Rande der Straße Menschen verscharrt
wurden die gefoltert und hingerichtet
wurden ähnlich wie in Butcher ein
Dorfbewohner hatte den Hinweis gegeben
und nach einer Stunde entdecken die
Polizisten tatsächlich die Leichen von
zwei Männern
wir bestätigen zusammen mit den
eingeladenen Experten Schusswunden und
fehlende Ohren das ist nicht die einzige
Gräueltat die die Russen hier begangen
haben wir haben zwei weitere Fälle in
diesem Ort
jedes Kriegsverbrechen genau zu
dokumentieren ist den Ukrainern wichtig
doch noch werden die Ermittlungen
erschwert war das Gelände vermiet ist
wie viele der Bewohner zurückkehren
werden ist noch unklar und dann liegt
ein schwieriger Wiederaufbau vor ihnen
es ist immer ein gewisses Risiko wenn
der CSU-Chef auf dem Parteitag der CDU
redet teilt er zu deftig bayerisch aus
sieht die schwesternpartei dagegen Kreuz
brav aus geriert sich Söder lammfromm
glaubt man ihm kein Wort stichelte aber
verzagen stichelte aber zu heftig gegen
den unionspartner
ärgern sich die Delegierten heute also
war es wieder soweit Auftritt Söder am
Tag 2 des cdu-parteitags und offenbar
hat die Union zumindest bis zur
Bayernwahl ein bisschen was aus dem
waldebakel des letzten Jahres gelernt
mattes Feldhoff berichtet aus Hannover
es ist nur ein kleiner fingerzeigtes
CSU-Chefs auf die Person die das Jahr
aus Sicht der Union perfekt machen soll
nach NRW und Schleswig-Holstein soll
Bernd Althusmann Ministerpräsident in
Niedersachsen werden und dazu gibt sich
Markus Söder bei seinem Auftritt alle
Mühe Harmonie zu verbreiten und ein
bisschen Abbitte zu leisten ich weiß
2021 war nicht unser bestes Jahr es sind
viele Fehler gemacht worden von allen
natürlich auch von mir Söder steigt ein
in die Attacken auf die Ampel die Grünen
und vor allem Robert Habeck sind ein
dankbares Ziel er riskiert einen
schweren Blackout und Schaden für unser
Land
er trägt dafür die persönliche
Verantwortung das ist der Sound der
totalen Ahnungslosigkeit und so ein
Minister darf eigentlich nicht für die
Wirtschaft sprechen es ist die Kritik an
der Regierung welche die Union derzeit
eint denn das die CDU intern teils Grund
verschiedene Auffassungen zur
Gesellschaft vertritt macht ein tiefen
Riss deutlich gestern bei der
Frauenquote heute beim Begriff der
Gleichstellung was wir nicht brauchen
ist ein Staat der sich anmaßt in
Lebensentscheidungen Erwachsener Frauen
und Männer korrigierend einzugreifen und
für Gleichstellung da noch für
tatsächliche Gleichstellung in allen
Lebensbereichen zu sorgen der Vorschlag
den Begriff Gleichstellung aus den
Grundsätzen zu streichen lässt manchen
gleich an der Ernsthaftigkeit dieser
Forderung zweifeln wenn ich ihnen
vorlese welchen Unsinn manche liberale
über Freiheit sagen der käme denn auf
die Idee Freiheit zu streichen
auch bei der Tarifautonomie prallen
Welten aufeinander genauso wie beim
Vorschlag für ein verpflichtendes
Dienstjahr für junge Leute damit eine
Gesellschaft
Funktion braucht auch Pflichten ich
glaube wir sollten daraus lernen aus dem
Hashtag nie wieder CDU aus den
Entscheidungen rund ums Thema
uploadfilter die Klimapolitik oder die
corona-maßnahmen wo wir häufig genug der
jungen Generation vor den Kopf gestoßen
haben die CDU gefällt sich derzeit bei
der Selbstfindung ein ganz bewusster
Prozess der noch zwei Jahre dauern soll
gleichzeitig will man bereit sein die
Regierung zu übernehmen manche
Grundsatzfrage muss dann noch
ausdiskutiert werden
und gleich schauen wir natürlich noch
nach London auf die Ausrufung des neuen
Königs zunächst aber die Nachrichten die
Schweiz hat sich für den Standort eines
Endlagers für Atommüll entschieden
Gundula ja nach jahrelanger Suche wurde
jetzt die Region bekannt gegeben
nördlich Lägern wenige Kilometer südlich
der deutschen Gemeinde Hohentengen in
Baden-Württemberg ab 2050 sollen dort
9.300 Kubikmeter hoch radioaktive und
mehr als 70.000 Kubikmeter schwach und
mittelradioaktive Abfälle eingelagert
werden noch laufen in der Schweiz 4 AKW
wegen der Gaskrise warnt der deutsche
Städte und Gemeindebund im kommenden
Winter vor flächendeckenden
Stromausfällen
Hauptgeschäftsführer Landsberg sagte der
Welt am Sonntag die Gefahr einer
Überlastung der Stromnetzes sei groß
sollten in einer Gas Notlage die 650.000
in diesem Jahr verkauften Heizlüfter ans
Netz gehen dagegen halten Experten das
Stromnetz für gut gewappnet
der Reformweg deutscher Katholiken der
Synodale Weg ist nicht gescheitert so
das Fazit von Bischof betzing dem
Vorsitzenden der Bischofskonferenz
mehrfach hatte eher
sitzungsunterbrechungen beantragt für
krisenberatungen mit den Bischöfen ein
Ergebnis ab 2026 sollen katholische
Laien in einem Synodalen Rat dauerhaft
über Veränderungen mit beraten etwa über
die Zulassung von Frauen zu allen
kirchlichen Ämtern
der US-Bundesstaat New York hat den
Katastrophenfall ausgerufen weil in
mehreren Bezirken Polioviren in
Abwasserproben gefunden worden sind vor
allem Kinder wurden zu Impfungen
aufgerufen bereits im Juli war ein Fall
von Kinderlähmung aufgetreten nachdem
die Viruserkrankung in den USA als
ausgerottet galt
zehn Tage lang dauert die Trauer um die
Verstorbene britische Königin deren Sarg
ab morgen zuerst in Edinburgh aufgebaut
wird parallel dazu beginnt die Ära eines
neuen Monarchen den viele auch schon
über 70 Jahre kennen Prinz Charles jetzt
König Charles III er wurde heute in
einem etwas antiquierten Zeremoniell
offiziell ausgerufen
wer nach Zeichen suchte was für ein
König Charles III sein wird konnte
vielleicht in diesem Bild ein neues
Streben nach Harmonie entdecken die
beiden zerstrittenen Enkel der Queen
zeigten sich mit ihren Ehefrauen dem
trauernden Volk Yasin herlein aus London
es wird oft bemüht das Wort historisch
in diesen Tagen doch in dem Palast der
einst von Heinrich dem achten erbaut
wurde ereignete sich heute tatsächlich
historisches
nicht nur wurde hier ein neuer König
ernannt was sich dort drinnen nach
uralter Tradition Tat wurde erstmalig
auch im Fernsehen übertragen unter
anderem sechs ehemalige Premierminister
waren zugegen als dem sogenannten
accession Council dem
thronbesteigungsrat die Aufgabe zu viel
den neuen Monarchen auszurufen
der Faktor war Charles das schon seit
jenem Moment da die Queen am Donnerstag
zum letzten Mal die Augen schloss doch
vielleicht wird der Nation und womöglich
ihn selbst erst jetzt wirklich bewusst
in welch große Fußstapfen er da tritt in
tecking wenn ich nun diese Verantwortung
übernehme werde ich versuchen dem
Beispiel zu folgen dass mir vorgegeben
wurde
um
konstitutionelles regieren zu
gewährleisten sowie Frieden Harmonie und
Wohlstand der Menschen dieser Inseln und
der Territorien das Commonwealth
musste der neue König schwören und eine
Erklärung unterschreiben ganz so wie
seine vielen Vorgänger über die
Jahrhunderte dies auch taten
bis auch draußen vor dem ST jamesis
Palast unter Fanfaren sein Name
verkündet wurde
in der Londoner City später dann auch
noch einmal und wer sich jetzt fragt
warum sich das alles so häufig
wiederholt das Prozedere dem hier
gefolgt wurde stammt noch aus einer Zeit
als berittene Herolde durchs Land zogen
und die Nachricht von Tod des Monarchen
und den Namen des neuen verbreiteten
vor dem Palast legten die Soldaten ihre
Waffen nieder und nahmen die
Bärenfellmützen ab und dann durften sich
alle in der neuen Zeile in der
Nationalhymne üben
die Rituale sind die alten der König
jedoch ein neuer ob es einer sein wird
der die Briten über den Verlust seiner
Vorgängerin hinweg zu trösten vermag
wird sich erst noch weisen müssen
und wir nehmen uns noch Zeit für das
samstagsritual der gewinnzahlen vom
Lotto wie immer ohne Gewähr 1 2 12 13 26
42 Superzahl 9 weitere Gewinnzahlen auf
Lotto zdf.de und im zdf-text auf Seite
die Sonne setzt sich erst am Montag
durch morgen bleibt es wolkig und
durchwachsen im Osten und Südosten
überwiegen die Wolken und es gibt
Schauer und Gewitter sonst bleibt es
meist trocken zum Nachmittag wird es
freundlicher bei 17 bis 23 Grad am
Montag vor allem im Süden viel Sonne und
bis zu 28 Grad im Norden kommen am
Dienstag Schauer auf ja Mittwoch auch
den Süden erreichen
das war es von uns und alles vom Sport
jetzt gleich im Sportstudio mit Sven
Voss und uns gibt es morgen wieder einen
schönen Abend und Tschüss tschüss
[Musik]